this one looks like it's empty you're
right
i'm like look at all this stuff in an
empty dish
but it's salt
[Music]
hola gente welcome back to another video
i have been
absolutely craving moroccan chicken
pastilla so if you don't know what it is
it's this delicious dish that we
discovered during our travels when we
went to morocco a few years ago and with
this baby coming i've been having some
intense cravings and so we decided to
whip up our own pastilla but before we
do that i do want to mention that this
video is sponsored by amazon fresh so
thank you amazon and with that said
we're actually going to be heading over
to the amazon fresh whittier grocery
store to pick up all of the ingredients
that we don't have currently at home in
order to make this moroccan chicken
pastilla i am so excited i've actually
been dying to visit amazon fresh and
grocery store for a long time ever since
i found out that they started having
these around here i'm so excited to
check out the store because it's so high
tech it's like oh my god you guys are in
the future let's go
oh my god going to the amazon fresh
store was such an experience it was so
cool as soon as we walked in we got to
get our dash cart which is so awesome
because all you have to do is pull out
your amazon app on your phone scan a
code and then it automatically signs you
in which means you can then start
putting anything that you want to buy in
the store into the cart and as you're
putting things into the cart there's all
these cameras around the cart and lights
that actually register what you're
purchasing there's also a screen on the
cart that allows you to review the
things that you have in there it's so
high tech it's so awesome it was just so
much fun shopping because everything was
so organized beautifully and it just
really feels like you're really getting
the freshest produce you can get and
then once we finish with the produce we
headed over to the butcher section and
oh my god the way that they organized
the meat in that section it just
thoroughly satisfied the perfectionism
inside of me like seeing how tidy
everything was just ah it just hit that
spot for me so i absolutely loved
shopping there and at one point we were
actually looking for some almonds and
it's so cool because throughout the
store they have alexa there for you to
help you find what you're looking for so
i asked alexa where i could find some
almonds alexa where are the almonds you
can find almonds at all seven and isle
horn that is so freaking cool i can just
ask alexa like where is something i love
that the grocery stores are always so
lost and it directed me exactly where i
can go super convenient so helpful and
we also obviously had to check out the
baby section and they have absolutely
everything you need so i cannot wait to
go back to the store once we have the
baby to purchase all of our essentials
once we finished our shopping it was so
freaking cool because all you had to do
was just walk out you guys you can skip
the checkout line you just freeze on
through you leave your cart there you
just take your bags and you go on home
the way we just did we had such a great
time shopping at the amazon fresh
whittier grocery store i highly
recommend it so for all your grocery
needs and a cool shopping experience
check out your local amazon fresh
grocery store or shop online for
delivery click the link in the video
description to find a store near you all
right now let's make this moroccan
chicken pastilla i am so excited oh my
god baby you don't even know what you're
about to get
take me back to morocco baby so pastilla
is this amazing dish that we've had in
morocco
and it literally just it's like this
doughy pastry that has shredded chicken
inside and all these different spices
yeah it was like sweet and salty and so
yeah savory
savory i think we were in morocco for
like a week i ate it like four or five
times like i could not get enough of
this pastilla it was amazing um but the
recipe that i found online it's not the
tradition like the most traditional
recipe but it's close enough i think to
satisfy our cravings and also the
traditional ones made out of pigeon meat
we're not using pigeon today we're using
chicken yeah we're going to use chicken
anyway i am going to start prepping all
the ingredients this is a laborious
recipe there's a lot to this so i'm a
little intimidated but we got this hey
yeah
all right so we just spent the last 20
minutes prepping i haven't started the
uh actual recipe yet and tiff read the
first step how much do you need of this
little mixture that you made no well
first let me explain it asks for rasel
hanout which i
don't know how to properly pronounce but
that's we can't really and we couldn't
find it anywhere and it's like a
moroccan spice blend but we did find how
to make rasa
and the recipe that we found required
this much of all these spices in order
to create this product
but the recipe that we're working on for
pastilla just asked for
one teaspoon of this so we literally i
spent so much time right now just
creating this entire spice mixture for
just one teaspoon of it but it's okay
because that just means we're gonna have
more moroccan recipes in the future in
order to use all this it smells so good
though i know it was really good
can you smell it can you smell it what
do you think smells good right
oh my god we still need more spices
turmeric i have cumin ground coriander
black pepper aleppo red pepper which we
do not have we could not find so we're
going to be using crushed red pepper
yeah we need the saffron and saffron and
salt oh saffron
we finally get to use the saffron that
we bought in morocco so long ago that's
probably not even anywhere near as good
as it should be we went to morocco and
got some saffron
never used it once
oh my gosh this is hard to like measure
it's all under my nails
i have like 30 under my nails so we
learned that saffron is the most
expensive spice in the world they'll
have the
smell
even though it's years later the reason
why this is so expensive is because
saffron cannot be
harvested by any machine it has to be
hand-picked and that is the reason why
it's the most expensive spice in the
world you have to soak this
in one tablespoon of hot water whoa look
at the color coming out it's activated
all right so this recipe has a lot of
prep work i recommend you find yourself
some rascal hanout instead of making it
that took forever true
take the clean chicken thighs in a
cooking pot add 1 3 of the sliced onions
to it next combine the spices in a small
preparation bowl
add 1 3 of that to the chicken and save
the remaining spice mix then add 1 3 of
the grated ginger to the chicken add
about half a cup of water to the chicken
turn on the heat to high and let the
water sizzle lower the heat and cook the
chicken until it is well done alrighty
time to shred some chicken
[Music]
meat what are we doing now we're gonna
saute
onions add the shredded chicken
remaining spices ginger saffron water
chopped prunes salt herb
and combined it all
now i'm scrambling the eggs with some of
that chicken
juice and then we're going to add it to
this mixture after they're done and then
almonds
this is pretty combined whoa i'm nervous
okay unroll one of the sheets and
lightly brush it with oil
you can turn it a little bit
[Music]
now we're gonna put half of the filling
in
and then layer more sheets
and then put the remaining oh my gosh i
can't wait to eat this
starving
[Music]
look at that beauty and start folding
over
momentous occasion
oh my goodness
i finished ready to go into the oven let
me just double check that i forget
anything nope next is bake
is it the moment a truth it's the moment
of truth timer has gone off and it's
time to pull out
oh my goodness
be careful
fuego so now we gotta let this cool and
then we get to dig in
goodness
i don't want to cut it it's so pretty
all my hard work silence everybody we
are about to commence
crunchy cutting i'm so nervous
because what if i cut it all crooked and
gross and it falls apart or what if it's
not fully cooked or what i'm just
kidding okay
oh my gosh
[Applause]
ah i forgot it's hot i touched the edge
how exciting is that oh
it's amazing
we're gone oh
snap hey
[Applause]
oh that side looks nice inside don't
look at this okay
moment of truth
okay here we go
oh man everything's just falling off
because you guys are craving it
oh my god looking though come on
how do you end up doing that
it's not
obviously comparable to what we had in
morocco but it's definitely enough to
satisfy this craving
yay i did it we did it i didn't really
do much would you help me chop things up
true i did look
[Music]
that is bomb that is pretty close it's
pretty good it's good enough and right
the cinnamon and the sugar you can't
have a bastille without it you gotta
have that sugar on top and cinnamon
anyway i just want to mention one last
time that this video was sponsored by
amazon fresh thank you amazon and make
sure to check them out in the
description
adios
[Music]
you